tach zusammen und herzlich willkommen
zur zdf heute live eurem ihren live
stream zu aktuellen diskussionen und
ereignissen notbremse ist ja eigentlich
eine gute sache denn die kann leben
retten wenn sie richtig eingesetzt wird
und wenn sie überall verfügbar ist das
will die bundesregierung jetzt für die
korona pandemie bekämpfung eine
bundeseinheitliche notbremse
denn nach meinung der bundeskanzlerin
und ihrer regierung hat das mit den
ländern und der bundesregierung mit den
absprachen ja nicht so richtig gut
funktioniert irgendwie hat er jeder oder
jede das gemacht was er oder sie wollte
das war das gefühl der bundeskanzlerin
weswegen sie erst nachgedacht hat und
dann jetzt dafür gesorgt hat dass das
infektionsschutzgesetz geändert werden
soll das ist zumindest da willen der
bundesregierung ob der bundesrat damit
macht das werden wir noch sehen
die frage ist aber jetzt erst mal ist
das überhaupt eine gute idee kommt das
ding vielleicht zu spät oder ist es gar
nichts das richtige mittel oder
tatsächlich doch sinnvoll die ganze
maßnahme das diskutieren wir heute mit
dieser federle notfall medizinerin und
initiatorin des sogenannten tübinger
modells dann haben wir als gast martin
stürner virologe und laborleiter aus
frankfurt und bei mir im studio habe ich
für die juristischen fragen meinen
kollegen christian decker aus der
redaktion recht und justiz der sich um
diese ganzen fragen wird uns kümmern
wird wie läuft das überhaupt ab warum
wir bevor wir anfangen fast julia
schröter für uns einmal kurz zusammen
was diese änderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes eigentlich
vorsehen
es war der erste formale schritt das
bundeskabinett hat die änderungen am
infektionsschutzgesetz auf den weg
gebracht das ziel mehr
durchgriffsmöglichkeiten für den bund
und einheitliche regeln die in ganz
deutschland umgesetzt werden müssen
ist die sieben tage inzidenz drei tage
in folge über 100 soll es künftig
ausgangs beschränkungen geben
von 21 bis 5 uhr private treffen sollen
begrenzt werden
auf einen haushalt plus eine weitere
person außerdem soll der einzelhandel
eingeschränkt werden
nur geschäfte für den täglichen bedarf
dürfen offen bleiben
ab einer inzidenz über 200 sollen
schulen wieder geschlossen werden
da fragen wir doch erst mal den
virologen was er davon hält ich begrüße
bei mia marty stürmer biologe und
laborleiter in frankfurt hallo schön
dass wieder zeit für uns haben
hallo grüß sie haben es gerade gehört
was das ganze in kurz und knapp vorsieht
was ist das aus ihrer sicht der große
wurf überfällig oder nicht so sinnvoll
ja auf jeden fall überfällig das ist
eine sache die wir glaube ich schon sehr
sehr lange diskutieren ob es nicht sinn
macht einheitliche regeln zu machen die
halt eben trotzdem regional angepasst
oder incident gesteuert im online
ausgeschaltet werden und zwar insofern
bin ich ganz froh dass es jetzt endlich
passiert es vorbei wie gesagt meiner
meinung nach viel zu spät aber sie haben
sich am weitere auch schon angesprochen
es war ein so heilloses durcheinander
bei der umsetzung der maßnahmen im
prinzip das fazit der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin war eigentlich doch nur
dass man sich darin einig ist dass man
doch das tut was man möchte
jetzt ist aber tatsächlich die kritik
aus den reihen zum beispiel von bündnis
90 die grünen dass dieser instanz wert
100 nicht der richtige sei ich zeig doch
mal ein tweet von janosch dahmen der ist
hier auch mediziner und im
gesundheitsausschuss für die grünen und
er schreibt heute eine notbremse die
erst greift wenn wir vor die wand
gefahren sind verdient ihren namen nicht
was es braucht maßnahmen die wirksam und
zielgerichtet sind einheitliche
interventionen die frühzeitig wirken vor
der eskalation echtes krisen management
und vor allem krisenprävention können
sie sich dieser meinung anschließen
herrscht immer ja wir sind ja auch nicht
mehr vor der eskalation sondern wir sind
alle schon mittendrin insofern hat er
natürlich recht
das wäre ein viel früher anfangen müssen
und auch der wert 100 klar wir haben mit
der 50 angefangen
und die war ja nicht ein ganz
vernünftiger wert 2 werde auch gesagt
haben das ist der wert wo die
gesundheitsämter anfangen die kontrolle
zu verlieren
das mag sich in der zwischenzeit etwas
gebessert haben und ich denke schon dass
die 100 personen kompromiss wert ist
weil wir hatten ja diese 100 verankert
als notbremse weil die 50 ja gar nicht
mehr realistisch ist und wenn man sich
die deutschlandkarte heute anguckt
finden wir vier kreise die die unter 50
sind wenn es richtig abgespeichert habe
und dementsprechend würde ja
deutschlandweit die notbremse schon voll
greifen
man muss jetzt den nächsten tagen
abwarten ob die 100 tatsächlich der die
die maßvolle seine zahl ist es kann
durchaus sein dass sie tatsächlich zu
hoch ist hier gibt es jetzt auch schon
die ersten kritischen stimmen bei uns im
chat von abdullah laghmani zum beispiel
auf youtube ein jahr einschränkungen
haben nichts gebracht warum sollen sie
denn jetzt was bringen
ja wir haben natürlich immer angepasste
situation man kann die einschränkungen
in der form wie wir sie am anfang gehabt
haben und das infektionsgeschehen nicht
miteinander vergleichen wir haben der
flächendeckende ausbreitung die ganz
deutschland und das nicht erst seit
gestern sondern seit monaten wir haben
kolleginnen und kollegen auf der
intensivstation
die schon seit der 2 in der zweiten
welle und nach ende der zweiten gang zur
dritten welle schier unmögliches leisten
um die brauchen pausen und wir müssen
dieses infektionsgeschehen besser in den
griff bekommen wir haben eine neue
variante die b17 die sich durch
effektiver verbreitet wir müssen da
erstmal für entlastung sorgen über
andere dinge sprechen würden sie denn
überhaupt sagen dass wir gerade uns in
einem lock down zustand befinden
ja das ist auch eine gute frage es ist
ja auch ein uneinheitlicher zustand
eigentlich war ja festgelegt meinem
anfang märz das wäre wenn die institute
entsprechend hoch ist dass wir per
notbremse auf den stand von anfang märz
zu gefallen und das sehe ich in vielen
bereichen nicht gegeben runter wenn man
über den kanal rüber guckt nach
großbritannien nach irland die mit
dieser p1 17 war schon viel mehr
erfahrung gemacht haben
sie haben das gut in den griff bekommen
weil sie sehr konsequent auch die bremse
gegangen sind und das müssen wir auch
tun also insofern befinden wir uns
eigentlich nicht wirklich in einem
harten lockdown aktuell jetzt gibt es
hier auch stimmen die sagen zum beispiel
die gleichmacherei bringt nichts das ist
ein symbol
die tig den hessen ist nicht berlin und
bayern nicht schleswig holstein von
tiziano auf youtube oder blogger die eu
sagt nein nicht noch mal wir sollten uns
überlegen was doctors bisher gebracht
haben
wenn man welchen schaden sie bisher
eingerichtet haben wir werden uns
sowieso noch schwer genug tun mit den
folgen
lasst die leute wieder leben das ist
aber auch doch ein wunsch der doch sehr
nachvollziehbar ist oder ja zum einen
ist das virus in hessen und in bayern
und schließlich wollten das gleiche
also das argument dass das
unterschiedliches kann ich in der form
nicht gelten lassen das virus richtet
dort genau die gleichen schaden an im
norden wie im süden
die hausleitung als der teilweise sehr
unterschiedlich ja die einheitlichen
regeln sollen ja auch nicht angeschaltet
werden wenn jetzt im süden der republik
die inzidenz über 100 geht heißt das ja
nicht dass der neue zu machen muss er
hat der norden kann ja ganz normal
seine maßnahmen aufrecht erhalten oder
seine lockere aufrechterhalten sondern
die inzidenz dort eben entsprechend
günstig ist das ist ja in der regel werk
verankert insofern hat man regionale
abgebildet ich meine wir fahren doch
auch bei einer grünen ampel los und ich
bei einer roten ampel in einigen
bundesländern also wir haben ja auch
einheitliche regeln in ganz deutschland
damit fahren wir gut warum soll es beim
giro es anders sein ist aber sonst gibt
es dann kritiker die sagen zum einen zum
beispiel wir haben dann diese lokalen
ausbrüche zum beispiel in betrieben wo
dann 200 leute erkranken
und dann geht für den ganzen landkreis
alles hoch und dann wird gesagt die so
muss der ganze landkreis sich in
quarantäne begeben jetzt ausgangs
beschränkungen komme ich gleich noch mal
zu so weit würden dann greifen wenn es
im endeffekt nur einen regionalen herd
betrifft das kann man doch eigentlich
wenn man ein regionales gesundheitsamt
ist und das genau lokalisieren kann viel
viel besser handhaben oder nicht ja wir
haben ja in der realität gesehen das ist
scheinbar nicht immer funktioniert und
letztendlich kann auch ein rektor ganz
kleines ausbruchsgeschehen mit vielen
zahlen natürlich sich auch relativ
schnell ausbreiten es wird nie perfekt
sein dieses system und natürlich kann
man darüber nachdenken ob der pure
instituts wert der der richtige ist und
ob es nicht möglicherweise eben ein
bestimmter faktoren gibt die das ganze
mit beeinflussen können wie sie richtig
sagen das ist ja ganz einfach begrenzter
in einem bestimmten punkt nur wenn ich
das schaffe in einem kreis mit einem
ausbruch in einem betrieb die inzidenz
über 100 zu treiben dann drehen wir ja
auch über viele infizierte und die muss
man ja auch opfer handle und dass ich
trotzdem ist insgesamt als sinnvoll an
solchen regelwerk auch zu haben
jetzt gibt es auch kritiker die sagen
wenn wir mehr testen also testen testen
testen das ja auch eine strategie dann
heben die die instituts an weil auch
viele leute gefunden werden die
vielleicht überhaupt keine symptome
haben oder weil das einfach mehr mehr
infektionsherde geht die identifiziert
werden dann kommt es zu unnötigen
maßnahmen die in anderen fällen nicht
gegriffen hätten
man sollte deswegen noch andere
parameter dazu nehmen wir zum beispiel
die bettenauslastung was halten sie denn
darf und weil mehr parameter heißt ja im
grunde auch dass man sehr genau sagen
kann wie jetzt eine infektionsgeschehen
ähnlich aussieht würde also erst mal
wenn ich mehr tester finde ich natürlich
absolut mehr positive das ist vollkommen
klar das ist auch beabsichtigt
und das muss ja auch unser ziel sein das
infektionsgeschehen damit besser unter
kontrolle zu bekommen bei die die
identifizierung können das virus nicht
weiter geben aber es zeigt mir dann ja
auch dass meine instituts falsch
eingeschätzt ist nur weil ich jetzt sage
ich will die inzidenz nicht über 100
kriegen wir euch auch zu testen das ist
ja nicht sinn der übung waren wir müssen
eben diese zahl auch realistisch
abbilden und wenn es eben einfach so ist
dass die dunkelziffer so riss dann muss
man eben einfach drüber diskutieren und
erkennt vielleicht warum unser
infektionsgeschehen aktuell so massiv
ist obwohl wir doch wie viele
einschränkungen ja auch schon haben also
ich komme abends in die kommentare hier
gibt es noch mal eine frage was ist mit
dem einzelhandel bei einer inzidenz von
über 100 der soll dann zum größten teil
schließen hier gibt es die frage von
fritz neuer mit einigen ausnahmen die
buchhandel zum beispiel blumenhandel die
sollen weiter geöffnet sein unter
auflagen
und dann gibt es hier eine meinung von
dpd krawiec der meint wo sollen denn die
menschen aktuell die nach hin es ist
doch eh alles geschlossen und dadurch
erreicht man eh erst recht dass sich
menschen privat treffen und da kommen
wir zu der großen frage der
ausgangssperren die ja auch sehr
kritisch gesehen wird für wie notwendig
halten sie die denn aus biologischer
sicht eben genau auf den punkt was die
privaten treffen angeht
die ordnungsbehörden haben natürlich
kein recht einfach eine tür aufzumachen
und zu zählen wie viele personen sind da
drin das sind ja immer nur empfehlungen
die heißt haltet euch auch im privaten
bereich zurückkommt
mit der ausgangssperre möchte ich nicht
dass richtig nicht eigentlich verhindern
dass die leute an die frische luft gehen
das sollen sie weiterhin tun ich möchte
verhindern dass sich die menschen zu
privaten treffen auf machen und das kann
ich als mittel natürlich viel besser
machen wenn du auf der straße ist aber
die möglichkeit gibt man zu halten sagen
wo willst du denn hin und da wir die
menschen ja nicht dumm
die treffen sich dort um 21 uhr und 20
30 oder und 20 uhr gehen dann zu ihren
freunden und übernachten dann teilweise
auch das habe ich auch schon mitbekommen
einfach weil sie sagen das darf ich
nicht mehr hin dass heißt sie verbringen
unter umständen noch mehr zeit mit einem
potenziell infizierten menschen als dies
eigentlich sonst würden
und genau deswegen lohnt sich auch
wieder der blick nach drüben nach
großbritannien und irland sie haben
nämlich genau das gleiche problem gehabt
und haben die ausgangssperren 24 stunden
auferlegt und ich bin dabei genauso wie
das virus im norden wie im süden
gleiches ist es auch vor 21 nach 21 uhr
gleich runter da macht es dann auch
keinen sinn das ganze nur auf diese
uhrzeit zu beschränken
es ist zwar ein sehr hartes mittel aber
es ist ein probates mittel und das muss
auch nicht ewig lang greifen aber wir
können uns den luxus von vielen anderen
die ideen und diskussionen was auch zum
beispiel modellregion angeht eigentlich
nicht leisten wenn wir uns mit dieser
incidents weiter bewegen und wenn sie
die intensiv medizinerinnen und
mediziner fragen was die frau davon
halten werden die un haben die ja auch
schon eine ganz klare antwort gegeben
wir müssen die zahlen runter bekommen
dass wir nicht in ein chaos laufen was
die intensive pflege angeht da habe ich
gerade gleich nochmal eine
anschlussfrage von dazu aber hier noch
mal eine frage die an die
ausgangssperren anknüpft
gemeint ist eine frechheit was soll das
die wär's mit großraumbüros dicht machen
diese maßnahme die vermisse ich ein
bisschen in diesem geplanten
infektionsschutzgesetz änderungen oder
ist ein guter kommentat ein wichtiger
kommentar und ich denke dass die
testpflicht am arbeitsplatz durchaus ein
probates mittel sein wird dann mehr rein
zu bekommen natürlich sollte man dahin
gehen so viel wie möglich großraumbüros
abzuspecken so dass die entweder die
belegung deutlich dünner ist und so
viele menschen wie möglich ins home
office zu schicken und dort wo es eben
nicht geht durch gezielte schon für
heutiges testen dass das
infektionsrisiko auch noch mal deutlich
abzumildern also da bin ich natürlich
argumentativ dabei
eine einzelne maßnahme wird nie
ausreichend eine ausgangssperre an sich
wird nicht das probate mittel seien als
allheilmittel um die pandemie zu
bekämpfen sondern wir brauchen eine
kombination an maßnahmen und da gehört
der arbeitsplatz definitiv hat zu einer
nachfrage von markus sollte sorgt die
bundesweite notbremse noch für einen
bruch der dritten welle oder verlangsamt
nur den fortschritt der infektion also
das quasi kommt wie es kommt nur dass es
ein bisschen mehr auseinander gezogen
wird
nein wir haben schon damit ganz gute
möglichkeiten tatsächlich die zahlen
wieder deutlich nach unten zu bringen
auch hier wieder werden sie sich gerne
mal die zahlen in irland großbritannien
angucken möge wie das hoch geschossen
ist die instanzen während von werden
deutlich über 800 wie schnell die danach
dann auch wieder runter gefallen sind
das zeigt dass wir diese dynamik
beherrschen könnten wenn wir nur wollten
wir müssten halt einfach jetzt
konsequent zu machen und dann können wir
über alles andere diskutieren
jetzt gibt es ja auch modellprojekte wie
das tübinger modell dass einige dinge
vorsieht wie zum beispiel tests mit
denen man sich frei testen kann für den
einkaufsbummel dass man auch die
gastronomie wieder vielleicht benutzen
kann immer wieder ins kino gehen oder
ins theater
was halten sie denn von diesen ideen
also grundsätzlich müssen wir einfach
konsequent mal etwas lernen wir haben
mehrere locker und hinter uns und haben
gesehen dass wenn man danach einfach
wieder öffnen
das uns wieder erwischt mit steigenden
zahlen insofern sind solche
modellregionen sehr wichtig um einfach
zu erkennen und zu erlernen wo können
wir für gezielt wieder aufmachen mit
welchen begleitenden maßnahmen dafür
sorgen dass trotz öffnungen und eine
gewisse wartezeit oder oder normalität
in bestimmten bereichen einfach wieder
möglich ist insofern ist das modell an
sich gut es zeigt aber auch wie
schwierig es ist und wie das teilweise
unbeherrscht wird wenn einfach zu viele
parameter sich verändern
und ich glaube tübingen musste darunter
leiden dass sehr viele menschen eben
nach tübingen geströmt sind und das
ganze damit deutlich schwerer
beherrschbar zu machen
martin stürner vielen dank dass sie die
zeit hatten für uns diese fragen zu
beantworten und wem dieses tübinger
modell erst nichts im detail sagt für
die hat julia schröter das ganze nochmal
zusammengefasst
in tübingen sieht es bei gutem wetter so
aus nämlich als gäbe es kein corona
möglich macht das das sogenannte
tübinger modell das konzept testen und
öffnen
wer einen kostenlosen corona schnelltest
macht bekommt bei negativen ergebnis ein
tagesticket
damit darf derjenige dann zum beispiel
draußen im café etwas essen oder trinken
oder shoppen gehen allerdings auch in
thüringen sind die fallzahlen gestiegen
7257 menschen haben sich bis gestern
infiziert die inzidenz aktuell 118,1 und
ich begrüße jetzt bei mir die
initiatorin des tübinger modell ist die
notärztin lisa federle
schönen guten abend hallo guten abend
mit den änderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes wären
modellprojekte wie das was sie jetzt
angeschoben haben für das hier auch vom
bund ja doch reichlich mit lob und rom
gesehen wurden eigentlich nicht mehr
möglich was halten sie also von diesen
geplanten änderungen
also ich glaube die änderung hinter
weise wichtig aber ich glaube es ist
schade wenn wir unser projekt jetzt
stoppen müssten ich möchte mal ganz kurz
was anlagen also erstmal bedanke ich
mich bei hans stürmer dass er das ja
auch irgendwie befürwortet hat weil wir
haben im moment in tübingen selber haben
wir eine instanz von 80 wir testen
wahnsinnig viel das heißt wir sind
logischerweise am anfang etwas gestiegen
in der stadt tübingen und sind jetzt
aber auf einem niveau das deutlich unter
dem landesschnitt liegt ja die 80 die
inzidenz von 80 im verhältnis zum land
mit 150 ist gerade mal 60 prozent obwohl
wir seit wochen offen haben die
außengastronomie haben wir haben wir
mittlerweile geschlossen weil es
unbeherrschbar war weil so viele von
überall her kamen aber wir testen testen
testen und haben mit sicherheit die
aller niedrigste dunkelziffer in
deutschland und trotzdem sind wir bei 80
und da hätte ich schon gerne gehabt dass
man tübingen als stadt marl isoliert
betrachtet und nicht den ganzen kreis
den sie jetzt genannt haben
und dann sagt solange die inzidenz unter
100 bleibt in der stadt und wir das
unter kontrolle habe mit so vielen test
dass man dann das modell zumindest
weiterlaufen lässt um eben auch mal zu
zeigen besteht überhaupt eine
möglichkeit mit vielen vielen tests auch
in betrieben in schulen in kindergärten
ich arbeite ja seit monaten daran ist es
der seit november ja und wir waren der
erste kreis in baden württemberg der
unter 50 gekommen ist trotzdem vielen
tests und da das hätte ich mir gewünscht
dass und zumindest da ein bisschen ein
augenmerk hat weil allein die inzidenz
in meinen augen nicht die einzige
aussage ist aber wo haben sie denn die
zahlen über die stadt tübingen her denn
wenn ich mal gesucht habe dann war es
relativ schwierig da überhaupt eine
verlässliche aussage damit immer angaben
über den landkreis wo die inzidenz jetzt
bei 170 liegt also da wird die stadt
typischen damit eingerechnet also die
die inzidenz von der stadt tübingen
kriege ich täglich oder kriegen wir
täglich boris palmer und ich täglich von
stuttgart und die ging jetzt irgendwann
mal ganz kurzfristig über 100 weil wir
auch eine stelle hatten wo viele
infizierte in einem cluster dann waren
die hatten aber mit unserem projekt gar
nichts zu tun und wir haben aber die
hallen thüringen gelebt ja die haben in
tübingen in einer erstaufnahme gelebt ja
die waren aber nicht in der stadt also
wir haben jetzt ein erster bericht einen
zwischenbericht von den epidemiologen
wir werden ja wissenschaftlich begleitet
von vwl von epidemiologen und so weiter
und die haben sich jetzt mal vorsichtig
in diese richtung mit dieser these
gewagt dass das viele testen in tübingen
am anfang die zahl leicht gesteigert hat
aber jetzt er senkt das bedeutet die
sind die haben ganz klar sich jetzt für
ein fortführen des projekts auch
aufgrund dieser datenlage ausgesprochen
da muss ich trotzdem mal kurz zwischen
haken diese die sagt dieses cluster was
sie hatten in der erste aufnahmen was
das wohl gesorgt hat dass die inzidenz
über 100 gestiegen ist ist das geht
das jetzt noch also oder es gelte jetzt
nicht mehr als infiziert oder haben sie
das jetzt mal für sich herausgerechnet
was sie sagen die waren gar nicht in der
stadt sein das ist mit rein gerechnet
und es war eben das hat dann die
inzidenz von einer weile auf über 100
kurzfristig gebracht den tübing wir
haben das ganz normal mit eingerechnet
wir haben nichts mit rausgerechnet das
sind die ganz offiziellen daten die auch
so der universität überliefert werden
und die wissenschaftler werden diese
daten dann aus und die sind genau zu
diesem schluss gekommen in diesem papier
das mir vorliegt steht genau diese
begründung auch drin aber sie haben auch
mit dem oberbürgermeister boris palmer
vor kurzem an die bürgerinnen der stadt
geschrieben wir waren gut aber leider
nicht gut genug die außengastronomie
musste wieder schließen bei ihnen in der
stadt
das heißt also so ganz dass man sagen
kann mit diesen testen können wir uns
ganz normal bewegen das scheint ja auch
nicht der fall zu sein man muss dann
doch immer wieder nachjustieren
natürlich das müssen sie in einer
epidemie immer vor allen dingen wenn
zehn pilotprojekt haben haben sie ja
keine vorlage wie sie sich verhalten
können sondern sie müssen sich quasi von
woche zu woche vortasten das ist ja ganz
klar wir werden ja irre wenn wir das
vorher fest schreiben und sagen das
bleibt so egal was passiert wir waren
schon etwas überrascht dass ganz
deutschland plötzlich bei uns kaffee
trinken gehen wollte also und die die
ordnungskräfte haben das einfach nicht
im griff gekriegt und das war das
problem
wir wollten aber auch gleichzeitig dann
natürlich nicht dass unsere zahlen total
verfälscht werden weil normal ist es ja
nicht dass in einer stadt ganz
deutschland sich aufhält deswegen haben
sie auch ein riegel vorgeschoben
dann geht auch genau und das fand ich
absolut richtig weil also ich meine
trotz allem bin ich ärztin und nicht
event managerin oder sonst irgendwas in
die richtung ja also mir ist es schon
wichtig dass die tübinger bürger
geschützt sind und das allerhöchste ziel
ist für mich schon mal eben das leben
der menschen zu schützen ich möchte aber
eins wirklich noch mal ganz kurz sagen
was ich ganz schlimm finde es wir haben
zb in tübingen eine absolut überfüllte
kinder und jugendpsychiatrie
die zunehmend in meiner praxis auch von
jungen menschen zu hören die depressiv
werden essstörungen haben zum psychiater
müssen zum psychotherapeuten müssen usw
ich glaube dass wir da gerade mal die
spitze des eisbergs sehen und ich glaube
da wird auf uns was zu kommen was uns im
moment noch gar nicht klar ist und das
müssen wir auch mit bedenken und ich
glaube einfach wir müssen ganz klar die
schulen die kindergärten maximal testen
und beschützen aber auch aufmachen das
ist für mich inzwischen völlig klar
und da finde ich das sind wir einfach
dass ständig hinterher aber das sagen
hat ja auch die regierungen jetzt
vorgeschlagen dass also vorgesehen dass
quasi die kindergärten und schulen als
letztes schließen sollen wenn der
instanz werde in einem landkreis über
200 liegt das ist ja doch ein relativ
hoher wert
den würden in deutschland also nicht die
meisten landkreise zurzeit erreichen
aber ich habe auch verstanden dass sie
diesen instituts werk per se jetzt nicht
für das maß aller dinge erhalten
da gibt es auch andere stimmen zum
beispiel den oberbürgermeister von
leipzig burkhard jung von der spd der
hat mal folgendes dazu gesagt ich
plädiere in der tat noch darüber hinaus
einen zweiten wert einzuführen und das
ist die belegung der betten
wir können ganz einfach vermitteln wenn
uns die bettenkapazitäten nicht mehr zur
verfügung stehen da müssen wir was tun
und das versteht auch jeder als das wäre
mein petitum ich würde mir wünschen dass
zu der inzidenz von 100 respektive 201
einer notbremse gezogen werden kann bei
der belegung der intensivbetten frau
fehler ist das wirklich eine gute idee
sie als ärztin wissen ja auch es dauert
bis zu 1
corona fall mein coruna patient
tatsächlich im krankenhaus landet dann
in der auf der intensivstation
vielleicht landet dort beatmet werden
muss das heißt wenn man erst dann
umschaltet werden die krankenhäuser
volllaufen ist es im endeffekt doch
schon zu spät oder aber sie ja aber da
davon rät seit monaten ich rede seit
oktober von schnelltests und von autun
strategie also ganz ehrlich und kämpfe
seit monaten darum und ich weiß es nicht
wir haben es ja nicht ausprobiert aber
ich finde es ist viel zu spät wir hätten
viel früher in den schulen testen sollen
auch in den präsenzunterricht schon ja
und in der not in den kitas die note
geöffnet waren bei uns gab's da ständig
dann irgendwann irgendwelche ausbrüche
und deswegen bin ich auch rein gegangen
und habe gesagt zum haben palma
wir testen jetzt die schulen und wir
bringen den lehrern des bei wie die
selber getestet sich testen können und
ich habe am ersten februar die lehrerein
gelernt und ich kann ihnen sagen im
moment ist es zumindest bei uns so dass
unsere intensivstation nicht überfüllt
ist und dass tübingen statt wirklich
beinahe incidents von 80 ist ich möchte
jetzt überhaupt nichts beschwören
verstehen sie aber eins kann ich nicht
verstehen dass wir nicht viel früher auf
diesen zug aufgesprungen sind und das
jetzt so langsam wäre endlich mal dazu
kommen zu sagen man muss die betriebe
testen
ich habe vor ich habe mitte februar
schon die ihk die betriebe ein gelernt
und alles und gesagt die betriebe
sollten sich rechtzeitig testen können
sie in tübingen nachfragen ich kann es
nicht verstehen dass die politik immer
viel zu spät ist und jetzt sind wir im
dritten block da und das ist wichtig
weil wir eben nicht vorgesorgt haben
weil wir eben keine tests kapazitäten
und testmöglichkeiten für schulen
überall geschafft haben wir diskutieren
im moment ja erst mal drüber
da gab es ja auch immer jetzt die
begründung es gab gar nicht ausreichend
tests für das ganze land das ist ja auch
so ein bisschen das problem was wir am
anfang der ganzen patinierten masken
hatten
stimmt im oktober letzten jahres gab es
nicht genügend es seit januar diesen
jahres gibt es genügend es das kann ich
auch beweisen ich habe allein für baden
württemberg 25 millionen tests sofort
angeboten gekriegt und sie wissen selbst
wenn die nachfrage hoch ist dann steigt
auch also wenn der bedarf steigt steigt
auch ganz klar die produktion also ich
weiß von den von den schnelltests von
den summen dass viele im lager liegen
nach wie vor aber das licht auf getestet
also hat also viele bundesländer haben
dass er jetzt eingeführt teilweise auch
verpflichtend dass du der kräfte sich
zweimal die woche testen müssen ich weiß
das aus hamburg von meiner frau schüler
innen werden einmal die woche getestet
das ist ein erster schritt in die
richtige richtung ist aber eigentlich
auch doch relativ dürftig oder ich weiß
nicht wie oft wird bei ihnen getestet
also ich habe immer gesagt ich finde es
wichtig zwei bis drei mal zu testen und
am besten testen geht über in wie
zähneputzen irgendwann ja es gibt ja
immer mehr schnelltests die man auch
selber oder sogenannte selbst fest man
muss es irgendwann den die verantwortung
der bürger übergeben weil sonst nicht
möglich ist das durch zu führen
das wird auch hier zu teuer auch das
habe ich gesagt ja und ich finde es
richtig dass jetzt getestet wird in
schulen aber wir sind zu spät dran wir
hätten dieses ganze system schon im
januar aufbauen können und für mich ist
schon die frage ob dann wirklich so
viele schulen solche cluster gehabt
hätten also ich meine wir haben ja
festgestellt dass sowohl in betrieben
wir auch in schulen das infektionsrisiko
einfach da ist und wir wussten
irgendwann dass diese mut an der eben
nicht so locker ist und das will mit bbb
117 eben nicht zu locker fertig werden
wie davor
und jetzt fragen mich halt wenn wir
jetzt nicht eine klare strategie auch
für die zukunft planen und uns nicht nur
ausschließlich aufs impfen was ich
absolut wichtig finde aber nur aus
impfen stutzen man sind wir denn dann im
vierten block da und dann kommt er auch
irgendwann wieder weil womöglich dann es
wieder eine neue mutation gibt mit der
wir auch nicht gerechnet haben und wo
vielleicht auch die impfung gar nicht
mehr wirkt es gibt es sehr viele
kommentare die schreiben impfen statt
testen ich glaube das schließt sich
nicht gegenseitig aus
aber letzte frage an sie müssten doch
eigentlich als zufrieden sein dann mit
dem vorschlag der bundesregierung dass
jetzt auch betriebe verpflichtet alle
mitarbeiter testen müssen die nicht im
home office sind zwei mal die woche die
wirtschaft hat sich so sehr gegen
gesperrt aber das kommt ihnen doch
eigentlich jetzt entgegen oder absolut
und nur dass ich nicht falsch verstanden
werde ich bin nicht nur für testen
testen ist für mich nur eine begleit
begleitweg zum impfen impfen ist immer
noch das allerwichtigste keine frage
aber wir müssen die ganze welt impfen
bevor wir einigermaßen sicher sind das
muss uns klar sein das hat uns bis zum
sommer nicht gelingen also das wird mir
wohl keiner abstreiten
natürlich bin ich absolut froh dass das
jetzt eingeführt wird dass die betriebe
getestet werden müssen weil ich glaube
alles wo wir die inzidenz runter runter
nehmen also alles wo wir sind da
symptomfrei
menschen rausfinden verhindert natürlich
dass andere angesteckt werden und
verhindert und rettet oder rettet damit
menschenleben ich bin ärztin und das ist
mir schon das wichtigste menschen zu
retten
aber wir wissen auch die kinder sehen
aber ich habe genau über diese kinder
hier noch einen kritischen kommentar von
32 10 das testen funktioniert mit einer
klasse grundschulkinder 0
das ist auch das was ich jetzt sage
erstmal anekdotisch aus meinem
privatleben von meiner frau weiß sie
dass auch durchführen muss mit
grundschulkindern so einen test ablauf
ist nicht ganz kompliziert aber
tatsächlich für den grundschulkind auch
nicht ganz einfach zu handhaben man muss
sich an feste zeiten halten
man darf nicht mit der test flüssigkeit
quatsch machen man muss genau zählen das
ist alles doch schon sehr komplex wie
sicher sind sie sich denn dass das
tatsächlich funktioniert oder das ist
nicht auch alles ein bisschen ist auch
mal viel gut testen und im endeffekt ein
placeboeffekt erstens haben wir gar
keine andere wahl was hast du denn als
alternative die schule zu zu machen also
bleibt nur testen natürlich werden wir
auch die wir hätten das was sondern
prozent sicher wer zwei ist testen auch
eine frage des lernens ja des umgangs
damit wenn ich natürlich eine schule für
die situation stellt die nicht einladen
die lehrer nicht richtig ein habe und
sagt macht mal dann kann es noch schief
gehen also bei uns haben sich einige
richtig super daran gewöhnt aber wir
machen das natürlich auch schon seit
mitte februar und nicht erst seit
gestern
ich weiß nicht seit wann sie das in
hamburg machen aber bei uns läuft es
eben schon eine weile und ich persönlich
habe die lehrer eingelangt und denen
auch gesagt wie es geht hat videos
hochgeladen auch an kindern videos
hochgeladen und und und und wir haben
nicht mehr diese test wo sie bis zum
gehirn hochspielen ja also sondern nur
noch die nasen tests also so schwierig
ist das glaube ich nicht ich habe ich
hab' ich habe tausende von menschen
getestet ich weiß wovon ich rede sagt
doktor machen sie hamburg in hamburg
läuft das seit dem ende der osterferien
also seit ungefähr anderthalb wochen
jetzt also sehen sie und bei uns läuft
seit mitte februar und ich glaube so was
muss ich erstmal einspielen und dann
funktioniert es auch besser ist doch
klar sagt dr dieser vierte der pantomime
auftrag der
thüringen tübingen und initiatorin des
modells tübinger modells ich danke ihnen
dass sie am abend zeit hatten für uns
und möchte jetzt noch einmal mit meinem
kollegen christian decker über das
juristische sprechen also wenn ihr dazu
noch fragen habt ihr das jetzt
eigentlich juristisch oder rechtlich
aussieht ist der christian für euch da
ich habe auch ein paar fragen
mitgebracht
christian vielleicht kannst du noch mal
für die juristischen dummies unter uns
zu denen ich mich dazu rechnet kurz
erklären wie dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz bis jetzt
eigentlich aussieht das heißt wer hat
eigentlich welche befugnisse und wer
darf eigentlich was machen also schon
immer also schon bevor es cola gipfel
gab kann man sagen hatte der bund ich
sag mal das erstzugriffsrecht wenn es um
die bekämpfung von infektionskrankheiten
ging das heißt der bund hat eigentlich
erstmal die kompetenz ein gesetz zu
erlassen und das hat er auch gemacht mit
dem infektionsschutzgesetz der bund hat
sich damals entschieden
wenn man die länder zugehen und die den
ländern befugnisse ein
im lokalen regelung zu treffen also
konkretes beispiel woran man da gedacht
hat ein badesee ist von giftigen
bakterien befallen dann muss dort ein
badeverbot ausgesprochen werden
christian warte mal ganz kurz ich höre
ich aus der idee wir haben tonprobleme
julia sein mikrofon und mikrofon schreit
nicht richtig zu funktionieren
bitte mal unten gucken ob es also könnt
ihr mal kurz in den kommentaren
schreibweise christian hört das ist doch
schon mal das wäre doch mal ein anfang
ist ja auch so ein knarzen bei dir dann
alles zusammen
ja irgendwie scheint ein kurz war drin
zu sein das da unten was drin macht noch
mal ein ton test ja ich sag mal was das
infektion jetzt ist besser ja okay wir
machen weiter also nochmal jeweiligen
geblieben die bundesländer haben
eigentlich das sagen was die fahne von
genau der bund hat die den bundesländern
das sagen über geben da man damals hat
man aber eher so eine fette gedacht der
badesee ist von bakterien befallen und
wir müssen den badesee sperren jetzt kam
eine epidemie oder pandemie wie corona
und dabei gibt es dabei dass die länder
durch verordnung regeln können welche
maßnahmen getroffen werden
so sind wir jetzt die letzten zwölf
monate haben wir das alle erlebt die
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidenten
treffen sich mit der bundeskanzlerin
es werden beschlüsse gemacht und
anschließend werden in den tagen und
wochen danach werden verordnung in den
einzelnen bundesländern erlassen und in
jedem bundesland gilt nur diese
verordnung die die landesregierung
erlassen hat und das hat dazu geführt
dass wir im prinzip immer 16
verschiedene ordnungen verordnungen
hatten und immer 16 verschiedene
regelungen hatten die eine eigentliche
alle gleich aus hätten aussehen sollen
oder weil das gab mir dann deswegen die
konferenz die gemeinsam genau der
springende punkt ist dass diese
ministerpräsidentin und
präsidentenkonferenz mit frau merkel die
hatte nie einen verbindlichen charakter
da wurden dinge beschlossen die er so
absichtserklärungen waren er stand zwar
in dem papier stand dann drin wir wollen
dies und jenes machen aber das was
wirklich rechtlich gilt das war das was
in den verordnungen stand und das oder
steht bis heute
und das ist eben das was die
landesregierung dann erlassen
und das führt dazu auch zu dem gefühl
dass wir alle so ein bisschen haben das
eigentlich ständig was anderes gilt und
wenn man in ein anderes bundesland geht
dann gilt dort wieder was anderes und
interessieren meint besonders lustig
einmal über den main gefahren und ist
man in wiesbaden und dann ist es wieder
ganz anders so dass eine entschuldigung
nicht mehr meine rein so ist es und dazu
kommt noch das natürlich innerhalb des
bundeslandes auch in den landkreisen
dann verschiedene regelungen gelten
können
und das ist wenn man das aus
juristischer perspektive betrachtet ist
das eigentlich schlauer sache weil so
kann man genau auf die lokale situation
reagieren man kann sagen in diesem
landkreis ist die inzidenz niedrig dort
müssen die maßnahmen nicht so streng
sein wie vielleicht in einem anderen
landkreis wo die inzidenz sehr hoch ist
das ist der status quo
aber das ist doch jetzt im endeffekt
genauso na also die bundesregierung hat
auch jetzt vorgesehen wir machen das
einmal einheitlich damit nicht 16
verordnungen kommen sondern eine
gemeinsame und die wird in den landkreis
jeweils umgesetzt also was ändert sich
da jetzt großartig ja von den regeln
oder für unseren alltag ändert sich
wahrscheinlich am ende nicht so
wahnsinnig viel wenn man mal vielleicht
von den ausgangs beschränkungen absieht
was sich ändert ist das eben die regeln
ab einer zahl von 100 jetzt bundesweit
die gleichen sein werden sollte das
infektionsschutzgesetz so kommen wie es
entworfen ist das interessante ist
unterhalb von 100 da gälten weiterhin
das was die länder erlassen das heißt
die länder werden ich an dieser stelle
eigentlich nicht richtig entmachte die
länder können bis zu einer instanz von
100 können sie immer noch frei bestimmen
welche regeln gelten sollen
der bund will jetzt nur vorgeben ab
einer instituts von 100 bestimmte
konkrete regeln aber könnte der
infektionsschutz also tatsächlich auch
besser werden weil das einheitlicher
würde da ist es eigentlich vor allem so
unsere gefühl weil das dann irgendwie
einheitlich aussieht aber ja doch von
landkreis zu landkreis je nach jetzt
sieht es wieder anders aussehen kann
also das ist eine schwierige frage ob
das am ende besser wird die man aus
juristischer perspektive wahrscheinlich
nicht so genau beantworten kann ich
meine wir sehen jetzt seit einem jahr
versucht die politik wirksame maßnahmen
zu finden und das klappt mal mehr und
öfters weniger gut aus juristischer
sicht ist auf jeden fall so dass das ist
ja auch wichtig ist dass nicht nur
einheitliche regeln gelten sondern dass
die gesellschaft also wir alle eine
akzeptanz dafür haben und uns an diese
regeln halten das ist ja eigentlich aus
infektionsschutz gesichtspunkten das
wichtig sind
deshalb ist es nicht nur wichtig dass
die regeln allgemein verständlich sind
und dass man versteht das gilt und das
gilt nicht sondern ich glaube das ist
auch wichtig ist dass man versteht warum
gilt diese regel und je verständlicher
nachvollziehbar in der regel ist und man
den sinn dahinter versteht desto höher
ist vermutlich dann am ende auch die
akzeptanz und deshalb umso mehr wirkung
wird diese regel dann auch entfalten
ein problem was wir je hatten ist dass
es diese einzelnen verordnungen gab in
den einzelnen ländern dann in den
landkreisen und das dann einzelne bürger
dagegen geklagt haben dann haben
verwaltungsgerichte gesagt okay in
frankfurt wird dort demonstriert werden
oder in hessen darf doch das und das
zugelassen werden ist dieses chaos dann
vielleicht vorbei dass einzelne
gerichtet auch teilweise ganz
unterschiedlich entschieden haben also
das wird ein bisschen sich verändern
vermutlich weil das
bundesverfassungsgericht mehr ins spiel
kommt das sozusagen für dieses
bundesgesetz dann auch ganz generell
sagen kann ist dieses bundesgesetz
rechtlich in ordnung oder nicht also ist
das verfassungsgemäß oder nicht dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz und da wird es
dann vermutlich schon mehr
einheitlichkeit geben aber die
landesverordnung die wird es aber auch
weiterhin geben also unter einer in sin
city 2 1
100 werden auch die die
oberverwaltungsgerichte der länder
werden auch da weiterhin zugange sein
sagte ich meine es gibt ja jetzt auch
kritiker wie zum beispiel die fdp fdp
chef lindner der gesagt hat im endeffekt
brauchen das alles nicht gehirn mal rein
bei einer hunderter instanz die menschen
aber 21 uhr zuhause einzusperren selbst
die geimpften ist unverhältnismäßig und
wenn maßnahmen benötigt werden dann
könnte herr söder in bayern
beispielsweise jetzt ja alles
beschließen dafür braucht er kein neues
gesetz
tja da kam einmal tatsächlich die frage
braucht man das überhaupt und dann das
richtige wort verhältnismäßigkeit das
glück die juristen jetzt besonders gern
die verhältnismäßigkeit ist sozusagen
der kern des verfassungsrechts und alles
muss verhältnismäßig sein
der hintergrund ist ganz einfach eine
ausgangssperre oder eine kontakt
reduzierung schränkt uns in unseren
grundrechten natürlich massiv ein
das heißt wir sind uns am lebensalltag
massiv eingeschränkt und für diese
einschränkungen die unsere grundrechte
muss es eine gute begründung geben man
kann nicht einfach eine kontaktsperre
verhängt
also ein kontakt ist ein massiver
eingriff in die grundrechte und
sozusagen zu prüfen ist das noch
angemessen diese dieser eingriff also
ist zum beispiel die ausgangssperre ist
das noch angemessen das wird anhand der
verhältnismäßigkeit überprüft und das
ist sozusagen ein ja sowieso ein
baukasten sage ich mal wo man genau
untersucht ist das verhältnis mehr sich
ja oder nein und zum beispiel ein
wichtiger punkt der da untersucht wird
ist die sogenannte erforderlichkeit also
ist eine ausgangssperre erforderlich
dabei wird unter anderem geprüft gibt es
dann milder ein milderes mittel das den
gleichen effekt hätte aber da ist dann
wieder die wissenschaft gefragt oder das
kann doch die juristerei nicht richtig
entscheiden da ist die wissenschaft
teilweise auch gefragt habe in erster
linie ist hier auch die politik gefragt
die politik muss nämlich dem gericht
glaubhaft machen
wir haben alles unternommen und jetzt
bleibt uns nichts mehr anderes übrig bei
einer so hohen incidents als eine
ausgangssperre zu verhängen
und gerade beim thema ausgangssperre
haben die gerichte in den vergangenen
monaten sehr unterschiedlich beurteilt
es gab da gerichte die gesagt haben ja
eine ausgangssperre ist in ordnung und
es gab aber auch gerichte die gesagt
haben nein das ist total
unverhältnismäßig also zb bei die
inzidenz gar nicht hoch genug ist oder
zuletzt hatte das oberverwaltungsgericht
lüneburg für die regierung hannover
gesagt hier konntet ihr gar nicht
nachweisen liebe politik dass ihr
maßnahmen ergriffen habe die milder sind
und vor allem diese maßnahmen
durchgesetzt hat und vor allem
kontrolliert habt ob diese maßnahmen
denn überhaupt eingehalten wurden und
solange das nicht passiert das könnt ihr
nicht zu so einem massiven mittel wie
eine ausgangssperre greifen
jetzt gibt's ja auch ein paar fragen
also die eine frage von till auf youtube
da habe ich ein bisschen das gefühl auch
als juristischer laie da ist ein
missverständnis in der geplanten
novellierung schreibt er soll nur
bundesregierung und bundesrat zustimmen
entmachtet sich der bundestag nicht
selbst damit ich glaub das ist ein
missverständnis ist tatsächlich ein
missverständnis also dieses gesetz hat
zwar heute die bundesregierung das
kabinett auf den weg gebracht aber das
muss vom bundestag natürlich mit einer
mehrheit verabschiedet werden und
anschließend wird der bundesrat noch
beteiligt so dass sozusagen sowohl der
bundestag als parlament als gewählte
volksvertretung dieses gesetz
verabschieden wird als auch die länder
beteiligt werden hier bei der
gesetzgebung die versuchen dabei gerade
richtig druck zu machen also irgendwie
sonst eher so eine art eilverfahren
geben heißt es nochmal kurz erklären was
das heißt also prinzipiell ist so ein
gesetzgebungsverfahren was was man jetzt
nicht von heute auf morgen macht sondern
das braucht eine vorbereitung und dann
muss man ja auch gibt es sitzungen und
dann geht das normalerweise in die
ausschüsse des bundestages und das ist
dort zieht sich normalerweise über
mehrere wochen hinweg drei hinzu jahren
jahres bisschen übertrieben arbeitet
aber das kann schon sehr lange dauern
und in fällen wo das sehr dringlich ist
kann man das extrem beschleunigen man
kann das im prinzip dieses
gesetzgebungsverfahren theoretisch sogar
auf wenige tage eindampfen
dass dazu braucht man aber eine zwei
drittel mehrheit innerhalb des
bundestages um dieses all verfahren
anzustrengen
das ist ein bisschen so seien die
fraktionen zustimmen dass er das man auf
die üblichen fristen und das übliche
verfahren verzichtet und dann kann das
theoretisch sehr schnell gehen
aber das geht auch nicht von heute auf
morgen sondern es braucht auf jeden fall
ein paar tage am ende muss der
bundespräsident noch unterschreiben dann
muss es im bundesgesetzblatt noch
veröffentlicht werden
dass von heute auf morgen geht es dann
auch nicht jetzt gibt es in der frage
gebe ich mal weiter
von cedric wieso handelt es sich bei der
änderung des
reaktions schutzgesetz ist und kein
zustimmungsgesetz die frage versteht
noch nicht mal weil juristischer laie
erklären was ein zustimmungsgesetz ist
es gibt zwei arten von gesetzen
die unterscheiden sich darin wie der
bundesrat beteiligt werden muss
es gibt ein sogenanntes
zustimmungsgesetz und es gibt ein
einspruchsgesetz beim zustimmung zu
gesetz muss der bundesrat mit einer
mehrheit zustimmen
und beim einspruchsgesetz da wird der
bundesrat auch beteiligt er kann aber
sozusagen nur ein einspruch einlegen
dann geht das gesetz in den
vermittlungsausschuss
da kann der bundesrat auch noch mal
mitreden und kann aber am ende vom
bundestag überstimmt werden und wie wird
das entschieden ist tatsächlich
gewürfelt wahrscheinlich es ist so dass
diese zustimmungsgesetzen die
zustimmungspflichtigen gesetze die sind
im grundgesetz genau normiert das steht
im grundgesetz an vielen stellen steht
dran welche gesetze zustimmungspflichtig
sind und welche nicht
und das ist aber in diesem fall des
infektionsschutzgesetzes ist gar nicht
so klar juristisch ob das wie das jetzt
geplant ist nicht vielleicht doch
zustimmungspflichtig ist weil bisher war
wurden alle änderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes waren
zustimmungspflichtige die
bundesregierung der bundestagspräsident
und auch die cdu fraktionen gehen im
moment davon aus dass ist jetzt wenn man
das so verabschieden will
das ist hier nur um ein einspruchsgesetz
sich handle weil das für sie einfacher
ist wahrscheinlich na ja also es gibt es
gibt durchaus auch argumente weil das
infektionsschutzgesetz steht ist nicht
aufgeführt bei diesen genau den
zitierten im grundgesetz zitierten
zustimmungsgesetzen das ist so ein
bisschen umstritten also dass das werden
wahrscheinlich die nächsten tage dann
auch noch mal zeigen wie das wie das
abläuft und ob das wirklich dann dabei
bleibt dass der bundesrat einspruch
einlegen kann
man kann in dem fall aber folgendes
sagen wenn sich bund und länder an
dieser stelle nicht einigen
und wenn der bundesrat am ende sagen
wird wir sind mit dieser novellierung
nicht einverstanden wird das so der so
ein problem sein weil auch beim
einspruchsgesetz kann der bundesrat das
natürlich verzögern und das kann wochen
oder monate dauern dass dieses gesetz
dann doch endlich in kraft tritt und
sonders im grunde die pandemie eventuell
schon so ist es das heißt es werden
juristische feinschmecker wochen in den
nächsten tagen und wochen bin gespannt
was dabei herauskommt wir heute sag ich
ja erst mal vielen dank christian wird
seine einschätzung und erklärungen der
juristischen feinheiten die darauf uns
zu kommen und euch danke ich für das
zugucken
und für die ganzen fragen und kommentare
die er hatte wir konnten wie immer nicht
alle klären das ist ein großes feld was
wir hier bei a kann aber wir versuchen
euch bestmöglich aufzuklären und zu
erklären das werden wir auch die
nächsten tage wieder tun in diesem falle
macht doch mal die klingel an auf
youtube gibt es ein abo hat euch die app
runterladen gibt's noch eine push
meldung und bis dahin sache ich bis zum
nächsten stream macht's gut
und tschüss